في غضون ذلك فاذا مراسلون على الحدود
السودانيه التشاديه بسماع انفجارات ناتجه
عن قصف بالقذائف الثقيله على مدار ساعات
الماضيه في مدينه الجنينه عاصمه ولايه غرب
دارفور السودانيه
ان المعارك بين المسلحين القبليين مستمرا
ما يدفع كثيرين للفرار الى اجري في تشاد
ونقل مراسلنا عن شهود عيان ان الجنينه
تعاني من نقص حاد في مياه الشرب والمواد
الغذائيه وان معظم السكان غير قادرين على
الفرار منها
معنى من ادرى على الحدود تشاديه السودانيه
مراسل للجزيره فضل عبد الرزاق فضل اطلعنا
على الاوضاع كيف تبدو على الحدود وماذا عن
الشهادات الفرين ومن يحاولون
الفرار من ولايه غرب دارفور
نعم الوضع على الحدود الشعبيه السودانيه
في منطقه حيث اقف هنا ومن الخلف المباني
التي تبدو هي في ولايه غرب الدارفور
وتحديدا في بلده اديكون المحاديه للحدود
مع تشاد هذه المنطقه مثل باقي مناطق ولايه
غرب دارفور تشهد توترا مستمرا واشتباكاتا
في بعض
مثل ما وقع قبل قليل اطلاق نار في هذه
المنطقه وهي بلده السودانيه
واستمر اطلاق النار نحو نصف ساعه مما الزم
الجيش التشادي على
توفير مزيد من التعزيزات العسكريه في هذه
المنطقه وهي المنطقه التي يصل منها
اللاجئون الذين يفرون من المعارك في عاصمه
ولايه غرب دارفور الجنانه الى هذا المركز
بالامس عدد الواصلين الى هذه المنطقه نحو
ثلاثه الاف شخص فرو من الجنينه ووصلوا الى
كات لكن اليوم لم يصل حتى الان اي شخص
وبعض المصادر تتحدث عن انهم في مدينه
الجنينه وتحديدا في العاصمه عاصمه ولايه
غرب دارفور لم يسمحوا للسيارات التي تنقل
السكان الذين يريدون مغادره المدينه من
مغادرتها والوصول الى تشاد لان الطريق من
الجنينه الى هنا في مدينه ادرى يستغرق
بالسياره نحو ساعه بالكثير ويقطعه
المسافرون بسبب اجواء الحرب وكثره
البوابات والتوقف بنحو ثلاث ساعات ولكن
حتى الان لم يصل اي احد بسبب ما قاله ما
قالته بعض المصادر للجزيره من انه لم يسمح
للسيارات التي تنقل الناس من الجنينه الى
ادريبي الخروج منها اليوم الوضع هنا هذه
هي منطقه الهدود
لا يوجد اي لاجئين اليوم يصلون الى جاد
فقط عدد من الافراد كانوا في بلده اديكون
ولكن عندما بدا اطلاق
النيران
فرو من المنطقه باتجاه الاراضي التجاريه
وهو عددهم بالعشرات لان اطلاق النار من
هذه الجهه وكذلك من جهه اخرى في هذا من
هذه الناحيه اصوات اطلاق الناطيه من اسلحه
خفيفه ومتوسطه ولكن لم يتضح حتى الان
الاسباب التي ادت الى اطلاق النار ولكن ما
نشهده هنا الان هو ان الجيش التالي
زاد عدد العناصر التي متمركزه في هذا
المكان وكما تسمعون يبدو ان اطلاق النار
ما زال